all right so a lot you asked for a
spoiler if ik discussion of the film and
I'm happy to bang out a quick video for
that so here it is warning this is just
a supplementary video to my spoiler free
review that our release yesterday so if
you don't want to be spoiled click off
this video now but if you don't mind
being spoiled or you're just coming here
after watching the movie then let's talk
about it
also as I basically used all the
available footage out right now for the
review I hope you don't mind this
bare-bones
anything either they really have much to
work with right now now what I want to
talk about mostly is how much better the
film could have been like it really
could have been something to put a whole
new light of this franchise
so as I'm guessing you already know the
basic plot synopsis from my review the
important things to note in the movie
are the new characters and their devious
plot involving the augment as it turns
out Yuna the idol program is actually an
AI reconstruction of someone who died in
sword art online and this was developed
by different people's memories of her
time during Sao you can probably see
where this is going
doctor Shikha Moroz the developer of the
organ was actually the father of the
deceased girl and AG is her boyfriends I
think a common room boy here with her
partner or just someone she was very
close to but either way the plot is them
trying to fully reconstruct her using
the memories of everyone he was in Sao
so yeah any Sao player who dies in
ordinal scale gets their memories of Sao
taken away from them and one of these
people is Ozma which can actually see
here with us tonight aching a hit from a
dragon for silica as usual being [ __ ]
useless this serves as the main stake of
the game and is the crux of the drama
that happened which is good I like that
it wasn't something as dramatic as your
life being taken away but something a
lot more personal was being lost
ci no memory loss being a plot point for
drama is a common cliche in itself but
the way it was handled was different
from what we usually see what we
normally see was memory loss cliche is a
character losing all their memories
thus resetting their relationship with
every other character and the drama
comes from not the amnesia of victims
themselves but from everyone around them
as they try their best to rebuild the
relationship they had before in ordinal
scale all that's lost is people's memory
of Sao and everything that happened in
that game no relationships are reset an
arsenal of course still loves Kirito but
imagine losing some of your first
memories you had with say your best
friend or in this case your partner
obviously you're still best friends with
them because you still have your memory
from after that time so your
relationship has not changed but not
being able to remember how you met them
or indeed why you even be
friends or lovers in the first place
knowing that there are some treasured
memories in there would be painful and
emotionally straining and seeing Arsena
quietly breaks out from that revelation
I genuinely fell for her and I didn't
think I could ever be sympathetic to any
of these characters now let's talk about
the antagonist and the general plotline
of the movie so dr. Shi Gamora was
trying to reconstruct his dead daughter
in AI form and I talked to people we saw
the entire plot of using everyone's
memory in Sao to reconstruct the
personality of the deceased person as an
AI program it's stupid and if he agrees
and I urge you to watch an episode of
Black Mirror called be right back it's a
short story about the girl who lost her
boyfriend and a car actor but through
new technology she is able to recreate
her boyfriend as an Android entirely
using the information from his post and
presence on his social media to
construct his personalities it's a
similar concept and obviously or handled
much more interestingly than there was
an ordinal scale but it certainly did
have the potential to be handled in a
much more interesting manner instead of
you know just making her an idol program
though I will say that one flashback of
UNIX luckily showing her dad the
nervegear was really well done
in that one scene you understood why
yeah I can kind of see why I was going
so far for this I mean any dad who lost
their daughter in such circumstances
could go to incredible lengths to deal
with the trauma of that then there is
Asia who I thought had the potential to
be a fantastic villain see the story
behind him is that he is also an SEO
survivor but in-game he was pretty much
a nobody he didn't make any friends and
wasn't really noticed by anyone or was
even good at it unlike Kirito who
excelled in the world of VR Asia was an
average player that never stood up or
did anything worthwhile but with
augmented reality he is a god douches
real-life athletic abilities as opposed
to Kira so who in real life is just an
average nerd living on cup ramen feeling
the limitations of his frail body in AR
he's the complete opposite of Kirito
from motivations to abilities to
backstory and the perfect foil Sakura
has godlike status that we see in the
theories he had all the makings of a
great villain who was not only a genuine
threat but also had sympathetic
motivations that really could have added
some depth into the theory so it hurts
me to see all this potential be shafted
almost as immediately as it was
conceived because almost as soon as it
was revealed here we said overcame
everything and beat his ass was like no
effort here if he thought Kyoto is
broken for being able to rise through
the ranks in aincrad by somehow soloing
or the bosses himself how about rising
to a top 10 player for the entire game
and what felt like
a single day if that even it didn't even
feel like his training montage went on
for that long the guy just went edge
murdered and suddenly he was told to
throw as ages we spent all this time
building up a genuine wolf or character
to climb that logically cannot be
climbed by simply winning himself to do
so and then he just overcame it by
winning himself to do so but here's
where I thought they really dropped a
ball because somatically ordinal scale
is an introspective look at the nature
of the sword art online experience if
this happens in the real world the
events of ironclad would have been
massively traumatic but Samuel is also
the most important experience of their
lives as in the case of kirito and asuna
they met each other through the games
found their closest friends and a
[ __ ] daughter and came out of the
experience was more than what they lost
compare the two our antagonist our
father who lost his only daughter to the
game and an unpopular nobodies you lost
the only person who you had a connection
with for the first time Kyoto's fighting
villains who are not pure evil but are
in fact sympathetic it makes perfect
sense why they have no issue erasing any
memory of sao or using the technology
for their own game because those
memories brings am nothing but pain in
fact had Kirito gone through defense
spirits they did and maybe lost arsenal
and sao he could very much be those
people really conflicts that wasn't just
good versus bad but a whole shade of
brave and it could have been used as a
platform to delve deeper secure eatos
own morality and question his own
position from what he himself had
personally gained from the game as
opposed to everyone else there was so
much that could have been done with this
so many ways to develop the characters
we had by putting them in the conflicts
I was not edgy
not slack of white and stems from the
exact experience that shaped them into
the people they are today just set up
was right there of course though none of
this ended up happening or was even
close to being expanded on we didn't see
any deeper morality conflicts or any
kind of development for that matter at
all all this had the potential to be a
franchise changing piece of work the
elements were there they just needed to
be expanded on understands though
nothing really changed Asia got his ass
handed to him but I don't know he was
just being kind of sort of used by sugar
mora who himself was apart from that one
flashback scenes nothing short of just
your cliche evil villain everyone got
their memories back and had a gay
outside and playing more games with all
the things that are done there was no
progression and just kind of felt like
filler in the end
shirley was entertaining filler but
nothing really changed when it's really
really cooked up some minor gripes about
the film well men
people have already mentioned that even
though this is augmented reality there
are things that seem impossible like
objects looking like they have weight
and creatures causing an effect some of
real world like wind and all that but
sao has always had a more simplistic
look at the technology is used and was
inspired by and without all of these
effect would have looked a lot dumber
and that's of why we watched it in the
first place so though it was never
explained I didn't really have much of a
problem with that
and if I could touch them something
quickly that I did actually like pot
down that last fight scene was
definitely worth the ticket price the
final boss turned out to be the original
intended final Sao boss and just the
scale of the scene made it truly feel
like an epic boss battles you see an
experience in MMO once I mentally got
over the fact that I wasn't going to see
the plot points I wanted to expand it on
I just had a great time watching it the
moment when they call back to everything
the entire franchise had done for pretty
much every names character getting
involved to go through all the old
design for everyone even I who am NOT an
SEO fan at souls got pretty excited so I
can only imagine how XA his fans would
have felt at that moment when he'll is
the moment where character got back in
black swordsman outfit with a jeweled
sword and I got a bit high and almost
immediately after thought god I
absolutely hate myself right now for
that but it's just assessment how well
the action team was done and how good it
felt to see on the big screen so yeah
that was everything I wanted to talk
about this film boilers in all if you
have any thoughts and just hearing the
spoilers or if you've seen the film
yourself and have anything else you want
to discuss and leave a comment in the
comment section as I noted starting
anime Phil's the hardest who's not
everyone has seen them and it's not
really a place to do so but apart from
that hope you enjoyed the video and I'll
see you all next time
[Music]